will The Surge of those three viruses is
being called the tripodemic and with the
rise of in respiratory illness doctors
often use oxygen to treat their patients
but necessary supplies are limited in
many places including right here in the
valley Victoria Saha joins us live in
studio with how a supplier is keeping up
with demand Victoria
Christian throughout the pandemic there
was a shortage of many items from PPE to
toilet paper and now a demand for
certain prescriptions and medical needs
Like Oxygen as we deal with three
different respiratory illnesses at the
same time
an oxygen concentrator like this could
be life-saving for anyone needing
constant oxygen maybe 70 of the items
are gone as soon as we order at CPAP
store Las Vegas buyer Marina Barbarian
says the triple demek isn't allowing
their oxygen supplies to stay on their
shelves for too long about three four
weeks ago we were sold out we placed an
order we received them about two weeks
ago maybe 300 units it was sold out
again she says they're seeing an average
of 40 customers a day when it's usually
about 15 and with RSV cases impacting
local hospitals nebulizers are
especially a hot product
they're either on back order and once
they are available then we order in
large quantities so we can keep up with
the supply demand but keeping up is hard
large orders according to on-site
respiratory therapist Scott Cochran not
just patients we've had companies
calling us we've had doctors calling us
asking questions
wanting to buy in quantity maybe you
know Mass quantity they say last week a
company out of Los Angeles requested 1
000 aerosol masks which need to be
plugged into a nebulizer and not only do
they have to deal with local demand but
tourists coming to Las Vegas try to
leave with oxygen supplies that may not
be available in other countries in the
past they would buy one machine now now
they're asking for two machines
the store tells me they don't give out
any oxygen concentrators or nebulizers
without a prescription ensuring only
those who need it will get it but
International tourists only need a copy
of their passport and when they are
short of advice they keep patients on a
waiting list and they get a call as soon
as an order arrives Christian